[Musique]
non
je vois ça s'est joué je pense que le
match qu'ils avaient dans les jambes a
pesé audi en fin de soirée
nous on était prêts on était 10 pour
n'était disponible on était engagée et
on voulait avoir une bonne chose pour
demain et jouer la finale du groupe et
se qualifier pour la finale
[Musique]
sur le premier match où je pense que là
on arrête je pense qu'on a cru gagner le
match déjà la première mi temps avec la
verve qu'on a eu en deuxième mi temps on
a eu un peu de mal en défense
physiquement on a un peu baissé et puis
vers la fin je pense que
psychologiquement aussi on en sait un
peu précipitée et ce qui nous a valu un
peu un peu cher après il a fallu
remobiliser les troupes à ce n'était pas
évident parce que ramènent sur les deux
dernières saisons on a fini à la
troisième marche
là c'était un peu compliqué pour
remobiliser les troupes
mais je pense malgré tout sur l'état
d'esprit sur l'engagement sur
l'investissement même si avec une
déception par rapport au premier match
on a quand même montré un beau visage en
face au dollar une équipe qui
qui habitués qui était aussi le favori
de la poule et puis voilà je pense quand
même étonnant aussi fait jeu égal à peu
près en même temps qu'on avait moins
quatre dents se trouve à nommer si cela
au nez à -5 donc ce débat on a quand
même fait une belle deuxième mi-temps et
puis je pense qu'il yad'autres d'autres
faits aussi qui qui vient qui ça joue
parce que notre championnat ça fait deux
mois qu'ils aient terminé en faisant le
ramadan donc malgré tout on atteindra
donc un mois de jeûne et ça quand on a
nos adversaires qui ont le championnat
qui s'est terminée il ya deux semaines
qui ont enchaîné les matches les finales
de play off ainsi de suite et que nous
mais avec quelques matches amicaux qu'on
a fait mais qui dont l'engagement et
l'investissement n'est pas toujours la
même donc là c'est aussi ça les 10 et
des petits détails certes mais qui
peut faire la différence aussi enfin
cumulés font la différence aussi
[Musique]
la bonne augure mais ouais parce que on
va en faire une équipe de la guadeloupe
est en confiance qui est tout jeune
nous venons proposition qui va jouer
crânement sa chance et quant à vue de
deux jeux simples à ses talents finale
mercredi donc nous on est prêts on a pu
grâce au score on fait tourner et demain
afin de bien jouer la guadeloupe à son
bon sens sans bobo
[Musique]